on july knife london comes to san diego  the assassins creed experience returns  with the all-new Assassin's Creed  syndicate court the phone never stops  come on look lively wrote last year over  40,000 fans learn what it takes to  become a Master Assassin  put your parkour skills to the test with  seven unique challenges  demonstrate your speed  get the drop on the enemies  showcase your agility  flex your muscles  of course a moving train  and if you have what it takes you can  perform the most iconic assassin move of  all the leap of faith off a big ben join  the family to skip the line open your  chance to win a trip for two to  comic-con international San Diego and  two now an assassin's creed calm /  rewards is the Assassin's Creed  experience welcome to the family  Assassin's Creed syndicate  you